matthias maurer trainiert hart um
dorthin zu kommen wo alexander gerst
schon jetzt ins weltall
jetzt viel schneller laufen ich könnte
jetzt 20 km laufen
auch eine andere koordination
doch der weg ins all ist lang alles
so existiert dass einiges los stehen gar
verschoben worden
in der kabine sind ein paar sachen neu
rund um die uhr werden die astronauten
von einem team aus experten betreut und
diese unterrichtseinheiten die
beschränken sich nicht nur auf den
astronauten und auf den ins coburger
muss zum teil eine komplette halle
gebucht werden da sind viele leute
betrachtet eilig ein beruf mit
gefahrenpotenzial
das hier ist die einzige einrichtung wo
man im wasser tatsächlich stärken kann
das training der astronauten ist
knallhart
ich bin ein bisschen fremd gesteuert
momentan man muss halt funktionieren
ansonsten bricht der plan zusammen
[Musik]
baikonur in kasachstan diese rakete
bringt gleich zwei männer und eine frau
ins weltall
einer von ihnen alexander gerst für die
deutschen ist er astro alex gottes segen
für eine himmlische mission der 42
jährige fliegt schon zum zweiten mal ins
all
wer weiß was ihn erwartet
jeder astronaut sucht am anfang auch
immer erst mal woher kommen sein
heimatland seiner heimatstadt und dann
nach ein paar tagen interessiert einen
noch mehr
ja vielleicht zählt das ganze der ganze
kontinent oder dann irgendwann
realisiert man dass dieser planet da
unten das dass die heimat ist
abschied per twitter von seinen fans für
ein halbes jahr verlässt ihn jetzt die
erde letzte nachricht vor dem start
steigen gleich in die rakete nächster
halt 1 es in zwei tagen wenn alles
glattgeht passt auf euch auf meine
freunde
erst ist der erste deutsche isaf
kommandant der weg bis zu dieser mission
war lang und hart
juni
freuen
[Musik]
ein jahr zuvor
das astronautenzentrum in köln hier hat
für alexander gerst dass astronauten
leben angefangen 2009 dadurch meine
grundausbildung angefangen das basic
training für astronauten sondern
anderthalb jahre kann man sagen
astronauten grundschule das haben wir
die basics gelernt worum es geht wenn
man den weltraum fliegt wie eine
raumstation aufgebaut ist wie ein
raumschiff aufgebaut ist wir haben
überlebenstraining gemacht werden
russisch gelernt wir haben medizin
training gemacht haben sport gemacht und
das sind so die die grundlegenden dinge
die man als astronaut beherrschen muss
sein basis training hat er ist längst
abgeschlossen
vor knapp vier jahren war er schon
einmal für ein halbes jahr auf der
internationalen raumstation iss ist doch
raumfahrttechnik entwickelt sich ständig
weiter
astronauten müssen auch zwischen ihren
missionen ständig im training bleiben
körperlich und mental
das geht nicht um ein starkes team das
von personen besteht aus über 100
mitarbeitern die ich hier astronauten
ausbildung durchführen da sind unsere
instruktoren zum teil
wir haben aber auch eine medizinische
abteilung wo es darum geht dass die
astronauten gesund bleiben da wird auch
medizinische forschung betrieben an bord
der raumstation und auf dem boden um uns
für weitere flüge in den weltraum
vorzubereiten
dann haben wir die astronauten
abteilungen dh das sind wirklich die
astronauten beschäftigt
wir haben einen cruiser porter sind eine
abteilung die die andere laden
unterstützt beim training in
logistischer art und weise ja und so
hatte quasi alles was wichtig ist um als
astronaut in den weltraum zu fliegen
eine ohne die hier gar nichts geht ist
er chris kam hell ist gerst sogenannter
special er legt das trainingsprogramm
des astronauten auf jahre im voraus fest
bis zu seinem zweiten start ins all ist
schon jetzt ausnahmslos jeder tag
verplant wir haben jetzt über die hälfte
von seinem training gemacht er wird
jetzt noch in amerika seien russland
einem monat in russland dann eine woche
urlaub dann drei wochen in amerika zwei
wochen in europa und so weiter geht
durcheinander privatleben gibt gibt's
bei uns nicht mehr sehen in den zwei
jahren nicht wenn gast in köln ist
trifft er sich beinahe täglich mit
seinem termin manager
der kalender ist randvoll mit
trainingseinheiten meetings und
öffentlichen auftritten
und der zeitplan muss ständig angepasst
werden so alex klar dass einiges los
stehender verschoben worden
allagui kurz durchgehen was sich dadurch
geändert
ende mai hatten sie jetzt selbst volle
woche ist mit seinem japanischen
kollegen ende mai mit einem kollegen
carl davis gesetzt aber möglich sehr
voll sein das wird anstrengend aber
dafür hoffentlich gewinnen noch ein paar
tage nachher das verhältnis es wirklich
so dass wir seinem leben für zwei jahre
organisieren wenn wir die möglichkeit
haben wird natürlich auch auf die
wünsche von von den astronauten
eingegangen angegangen also wenn er sagt
an diesem tag hätte ich da geht nicht so
gut also versuchen natürlich alles zu
regeln
klappt aber nicht immer also es ist
schon so dass er auch regelmäßig oder
die astronauten auch regelmäßig einfach
akzeptieren müssen müssen was wir wie
wir planen ja sie trainingswochen hc
sind traditionell relativ voll
das heißt man ist wirklich von morgens
acht bis abends um 5 mit training
beschäftigt und dann hat man dazu noch
sport man hat noch mehr administrative
sachen die man erledigen muss eine volle
e mail inbox jeden tag das heißt
letztendlich meistens sind das hier
schon so 12 13 arbeitsstunden tage die
ich hatte
termin manager kapell schickt alexander
gerst direkt weiter der astronaut muss
heute noch ein techniktraining
absolvieren in einem maßstabsgetreuen
nachbau eines forschungsmoduls der iss
erst ausbilderin für heute ist die
italienerin serena bett tolle
spezialgebiet das europäische module
columbus ich bereite noch das modell vor
gleich habe ich eine trainingseinheit
mit alexander gerst es geht um eine
einweisung in die betriebsabläufe von
columbus und wie das modell funktioniert
seit grafs letztem weltraum aufenthalt
gibt es im modul einige neuerungen
willkommen zurück danke heute gibt's ein
training am modell okay ja total
ich freue mich dass ich zwölf bilder
zurück an den ort der ihnen das bislang
größte abenteuer seines lebens erinnert
bei seinem ersten weltraumflug 2014 war
das modul columbus fast so etwas wie
eine zweite heimat für alexander gerst
insgesamt 165 tage hat der gebürtige
schwabe hier vor den augen der
weltöffentlichkeit gelebt und
experimentiert
seitdem hat sich auf der raumstation und
dem modul einiges getan
in der kabine sind ein paar sachen neu
aber die flagge ist falsch ja das ist
die von thoma also ein kurzer überblick
eml kennst du das mac vector ist immer
noch da plasma christi vor hast du schon
gesehen bleibt immer noch da macht immer
noch ärger dann was ist neu
das hier hat sich letztes jahr geändert
wir haben ein neues gelenk stativ das
alte ist immer kaputt gegangen jetzt
nehmen wir welche von der nasa kennst du
die witzige geschichte von meiner
zeitrafferaufnahmen eine kamera auf der
station installiert wurde
als da oben war ja ich war oben ich hab
die zeitraffer kameras in der kuppel
installiert und es wurde so robotik
verfahren ausgeführt und ich hab das mit
einem bild pro sekunde gedreht und ich
war so stolz auf mich und dann diese
also morgen installieren wir rapid
scannen und ich sowie morgen was habe
ich denn den ganzen tag gedreht
das heute das war und ich dachte so und
missverständnisse in 354 kilometern
entfernung von der erde kann schon mal
passieren
trotz täglichem training seine mission
ist natürlich ein bisschen weniger
aufwendig aber das ist auch kürzer das
heißt die arbeitsbelastung im training
ist eigentlich ähnlich und da bleibt
nicht viel freizeit übrig und da muss
man wirklich genau aussuchen was man tut
also ich habe wirklich bin da wirklich
hier sehr optimiert geworden das heißt
dass ich wirklich die zeit mit meinen
freunden versuch schon im vornherein gut
zu planen dass ich jedes mal wenn ich
hier bin und sei es auch nur eine woche
dass sie wirklich alle meine freunde
auch mal sehen und auch mal mit denen
abends essen gehen und so möchte ja noch
zurückkommen von seiner mission immer
noch freunde
alexander gerst markus effizient im
leben genauso wie bei diesem ersten
kurzen update in columbus modul hast du
noch fragen zu klampen alles klar
das bist du fit fürs spezialisten
training in ein paar monaten jetzt
endlich ein paar monaten klar ist also
danke jedenfalls danke dir schöne
nachmittag noch bis zu seinem abflug
wird der deutsche astronaut 10 leer
blöcke aus hunderten von einzelteilen
auf drei verschiedenen kontinenten
absolviert haben
freizeit fehlanzeige aber auch serena
bertone hat noch längst nicht feierabend
neben ihrer arbeit als trainerin für
astronauten hat sie hier noch weitere
aufgaben am sogenannten new york kam
eine art kommandozentrale stehen
mitarbeiter der esa rund um die uhr in
hör- und sichtkontakt zur raumstation
selena bertone ist hier dem
französischen astronauten thoma piquet
live zugeschaltet heute ist thoma mit
einem haptischen experiment beschäftigt
er hat die hardware gerade installiert
das ist im prinzip ein joystick auf dem
boden von kolumbus man kann die
ausrüstung da hinten sehen jetzt hat er
noch schwierigkeiten mit den tablets er
startet die gerade neu und dann geht's
wirklich los mit der wissenschaftlichen
versuchsreihe nach den jeweiligen
produkt die italienerin lebt und
arbeitet jetzt schon seit fünf jahren in
köln der job als astronauten coach
begeistert sie noch immer ja das ist ein
sehr schöner und ganz besonderer teil
meines jobs wir trainieren zusammen
haben also hier am boden miteinander zu
tun und dann haben wir die möglichkeit
auch auf der raumstation mit ihnen zu
sprechen
das ist wirklich eine tolle ergänzung
von training und zusammenarbeit
von hier aus begleitet sie als
ansprechpartnerin auch alexander gerst
seiner jetzigen mission
[Musik]
ortswechsel in darmstadt ist der
saarländer matthias maurer unterwegs zu
einem der wichtigsten termine seiner
karriere
er ist der neue deutsche astronaut im
team der esa und muss heute zum ersten
mal der internationalen presse rede und
antwort stehen
plätze danke beworben hatte ich mich
2008 und dann ging es ein jahr lang sehr
intensive tests waren insgesamt sechs
testrunden muss mehr bestehenden
achteinhalb 1000 europäer waren dabei
und nach einem jahr stand dann eine
liste mit zehn finalisten fest die alle
test bestanden hatten ich war einer
davon und ich war sogar mit alex
eingeteilt sozusagen einer vierergruppe
und ich weiß noch genau an dem tag an
dem die esa mitgeteilt hat dass die
leute wäre es dann wurde an dem moment
war ich auch mit alex am telefon immer
nur und endlich muss auflegen das handy
klingelt das war er hat damals den anruf
erhalten dass er ausgewählt waren ja gut
ich hab meinen anrufen tag später halten
dass ich nicht dabei war pressevertreter
zielbranchen begleitet maurer zur
pressekonferenz
wir sind auch die letzten momente der
relativen anonymität weil
hat gleich ab 11 uhr öffentlich zu sagen
ja ich gehe mal davon aus dass ich
vielleicht für die nächsten zwei wochen
öffentliche person winnenden ein
vergessen die leute was wiederum bitte
plötzlich im mittelpunkt zu stehen nicht
unbedingt maurers sache seit 2010
arbeitet der 48-jährige als ingenieur
bei der esa
aber das warten hat sich gelohnt heute
rückt er ins europäische
astronautenkorps nach ein traum wird
wahr
was haben wir jetzt in fünf minuten
haben wir uns erstmal gut
guten morgen meine damen und herren sehr
geehrte vertreter der medien
ich rutsche auf die bühne matthias
maurer er saß also ich heute schon seit
2010 bei der sache heute ist
was ist das für ein gefühl ja ich
natürlich ein unglaubliches gefühl jetzt
hier ab jetzt steht auch er im
rampenlicht
zu seiner vorstellung ist viel prominenz
gekommen wie der ehemalige deutsche
astronaut thomas reiter
eine erste hürde hat matthias maurer
jetzt genommen
doch der weg ins all ist noch weit
[Musik]
eigentlich also das geht so wirklich
wird am stück ich habe ja fast keine
zeit durchzuatmen
ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mal wie spät es
ist und wie viel zeit ich jetzt schon
zwei beantwortet habe also ja es ist ein
marathon aber es geht die eigentliche
arbeit liegt aber noch vor ihm mehrere
jahre astronauten ausbildung
[Musik]
köln hier auf dem trainingsgelände der
esa findet der großteil von maurers
basis training statt
die astronauten kollege alexander gerst
wird er hier alles lernen was man zum
leben und arbeiten im weltall braucht
heute steht eine übung für einen
außenbordeinsatz an simuliert bei einem
taucheinsatz im hauseigenen pool
vorher noch die einsatzbesprechung mit
trainer erwies der ena und den kollegen
matthias bist du bereit klar
warten wir auf luca wir warten auf luca
kommt nur rein maurers tauchpartner für
heute der italienische astronaut luca
pagano
er ist super ich bin noch besser dass er
gut in all das zeigen die nach einem
fernsehen
maurer soll gleich in einem
mehrstündigen tauchgang zwei
frachtstücke an der außenwand eines
versenkten moduls anbringen
eine arbeit die unter vergleichbaren
bedingungen auch an der iss an fallen
könnte akribische einsatzplanung ist
gefordert also erst mal von früher
am anfang sind wir beide an der luft
luca ist auf der seite mit dem kopf nach
außen
ich bin mit dem kopf nach innen auf der
seite was die sicherheitslage angeht
luca wird seine hier ambri und sie über
die vorderseite führen
trainingsziel ist heute ein sicherer und
effizienter einsatz
das bedeutet speziell für mich meine
abläufe mit den sicherheits nein zu
verbessern und mich nicht zu verheddern
die letzten mal
das begleitung macht sich für den
tauchgang fertig volle konzentration bei
der in bonn
denn ein unachtsamer moment ein
unvorhergesehener knoten in den
sicherheitszäunen kann zur todesfalle
werden
aufpassen muss dass meine lebensrettung
sozusagen wenn ich mich irgendwo
verliert auf der station dann brauche
ich nur das sicherheits kleine zufolge
nun kommen wir wieder zurück so war
flugzeug ist natürlich nichts weiter
letzte handgriffe insgesamt drei stunden
sind für den trainingseinsatz
unterwasser veranschlagt taucher
begleiten das astronauten duo über die
gesamte dauer wie phantome helfen sie
durch leichtes stützen komplette
schwerelosigkeit zu simulieren
bilder von ihren kameras landen live in
der einsatzzentrale bei trainer steven
[Musik]
schon zu beginn der übung erste
schwierigkeiten
du bist jetzt schon ziemlich verändert
matthias kannst du bestätigen dass
beiden spulen entsichert sind ja beide
spuren entsichert tut mir leid
ok dann eine konfiguration ist in
ordnung danke du schlägst sich gut
matthias perfekt
die erste hürde ist genommen maurer und
sein partner haben es aus der
nachgebauten lutz heuser nach draußen
geschafft
sie können nun mit der eigentlichen
aufgabe beginnen
zwei kisten müssen ans hintere ende des
moduls befördert und dort angebracht
werden
matthias so wird es nicht funktionieren
du musst die klemme parallel zum
handlauf legen sonst wird das nichts
nach ersten anlaufschwierigkeiten läuft
es besser die astronauten sind dem
zeitplan sogar etwas voraus
doch trainer ist die fma hat noch eine
überraschung für die beiden vorgesehen
also nach einer beide werd ich zum lukas
sagen beweg dich nicht mehr und sagt
nichts kein wort und dann ist es an
matthias zu merken dass der kontakt zu
ihr abgebrochen ist
da muss er sich im näheren und prüfen ob
das vielleicht nur eine verbindung
störung ist vor den grünen haken bei 09
er muss man prüfen ob blu
körperbewusstsein ist wenn er keine
regung zeigt dass er ihn wie einen
frachtstück an sich schnallen und zurück
zur luft ziemlich komplex das ganze luca
jetzt nicht bewegen und nicht sagen
der italienische astronaut folgt den
anweisungen
die one her alles okay bei dir matthias
maurer merkt dass bei seinem partner
plötzlich etwas nicht stimmt die vereins
bitkom matthias ich habe keine
verbindung zur ev1 kannst du mal
nachsehen so matthias wir haben
definitiv keine verbindung zu luca ev1
ist bewusstlos
du hast jetzt noch 17 minuten 17 jetzt
muss matthias luca retten und innerhalb
von 20 minuten zur luftschleuse
zurückbringen 20 minuten so lange könnte
der astronaut bewusstlos außerhalb der
raumstation überleben nur wenig zeit den
regungslosen luca zurück zur
luftschleuse zu bringen
ich verstehe nicht matthias was machst
du da
ich glaube ich habe aus versehen luca
tagen erwischt und hier ist bloss noch
sechs minuten verstanden weil ein wir
haben etwas ärger gemacht
wir sind gut die packen das ist das
erste was du tust ist luca in die
luftschleuse bringen dem kopf zuerst
alles klar
zwei minuten noch du kannst die lücke
schließen gut gemacht jungs gut gemacht
matthias
[Musik]
die astronauten haben die übung
erfolgreich absolviert wie matthias
maurer war die rettungsmission ein
erster harter test als neuer us
astronauten
bis zu seiner ersten echten mission
leben noch viele weitere übungen folgen
jetzt ist der 48 jährige erstmal platt
also ich freue mich jedenfalls daraufhin
erfolgreich im einsatz zu sehen
für heute ist schluss ford lässt denn
schon in wenigen monaten wird maurer im
astronautenzentrum der nasa in den usa
die fina hat auch prüfung absolvieren
dann in einem echten raumanzug und unter
strengster beobachtung der nasa trainer
[Musik]
bis dahin stehen aber noch viele weitere
trainingseinheiten auf dem programm
heute zum beispiel eine sporteinheit der
etwas anderen art joggen in
schwerelosigkeit
körperliche fitness ist für astronauten
vertraglich vorgeschrieben
viermal die woche steht sport auf dem
trainingsplan sowie läufe auf einem
speziellen luftkammer laufband es kann
bedingungen auf dem mond simulieren
[Musik]
in der trockenübung sei maurer seinem
körper schon mal an die ausnahme
situation gewöhnen
der anfang gestaltet sich allerdings
etwas freut mich
[Musik]
wir kennen
durch den kreis
weder noch
das führt sie haben wie auf der erde
die nation
jetzt 17 km h
eigentlich ist das für dich haben
spazieren gehen wenn ich jetzt den
köpfen machen
sich fit zu halten ist das oberste gebot
des astronauten
vorstellung das leben von matthias
maurer ist ab jetzt für die nächsten
jahre akribisch vor geplant
ich muss jetzt regelmäßig sport machen
und die wilden partys das ist natürlich
kein thema mehr
man fährt durch die
durch die gegend und hält vorträge
also das privatleben für ein bisschen
weniger
aber ich versuche einfach
so zu bleiben wie ich bin
mich da jetzt nicht groß unter druck
setzen lassen mich stressen
normalerweise machen die astronauten auf
der alles ist jeden tag zwei stunden
sport die hälfte davon dass fitness und
die andere hälfte bundes kraft fitness
ist damit der kreislauf in bewegung
kommt und die konditionen gewährleistet
ist die im kraftsport gesagt sport
betreiben wir damit die muskeln kräftig
bleiben die knochen und stabil bleiben
weil ein schwerelosigkeit bauen die sich
sehr schnell ab ich will das sind
hericks fertig vorbereitet prinzip dass
schon kleine stabilisationsübungen
stützen
zuständig für die fitness der
astronauten in keinem sport coachen oder
peters schon bei den letzten zehn
missionen hat sie die esa astronauten
konditionell vorbereitet auch alexander
gerst hat sie für seine jüngste mission
fit gemacht sie weiß ganz genau worauf
es ankommt die stabilisation dass es
relativ schwierig viele trainieren das
auch gar nicht nach vorn sondern
trainieren
oberflächen die muskulatur den ganz
schön sehen kann hier wir trainieren die
muskeln aber nicht so gut sehen kann
aber die enorm wichtig sind gerade eben
in hinsichtlich der vorbereitung für das
training im all weil wir da die
muskulatur nicht gut kriegen mit dem
training machen wir führen zwar das
tägliche training durch aber die
schwerkraft fehlt und dieser reiz ist
schwer zu reproduzieren und deswegen
versuchen wir möglichst stabil
aufzubauen bevor sich nehmen und greifen
wir es wieder auch wenn sie runter
kommen
das ist ein bisschen schmerzhaft also
normalerweise hessen astronaut kein
supersportler ein supersportler hat im
weltraum probleme wenn der zu großes
herz hast dann kommst du mit der
schwerelosigkeit nicht klar
das heißt man möchte eigentlich nicht
ein spitzensportler aber man möchte auch
nicht ein anti sportler haben sondern so
jemanden wie mich der in der mitte liegt
alles klar
astronaut sein was ebenso einen preis
[Musik]
also momentan muss ich fragen ihr meinen
bachelor habe ich morgen zeit darf ich
übermorgen diesen jenes machen aber es
gibt einen festen plan und das ist sehr
komplex den aufzustellen müssen ja viele
leute bereit sein und verfügbar sein und
klar da kann ich nicht einfach hingehen
und sagen herr am morgen habe ich jetzt
keine zeit oder keine lust
ja also ich bin wissen fremdgesteuert
momentan man muss halt funktionieren hat
man darf nicht krank werden ansonsten
bricht der plan zusammen
[Musik]
das amerikanische weltraum center in
houston
hier wird sich matthias maurer gleich
der wichtigsten prüfung seiner
astronauten laufbahn stellen wenn er
nicht besteht wird sein traum von einer
weltraum mission erst mal warten müssen
[Musik]
man hat mir gesagt wir testen die ersten
zweieinhalb stunden seine technischen
fähigkeiten
dann machen wir noch zwei stunden um
sich müde zu machen und dann kommt das
rettungsteam und dann wollen wir sehen
dass du wirklich müde abgearbeitet dafür
dann noch in der lage bist seinen
kollegen aus der einsatzzentrale
oberhalb des beckens wird der tauchgang
gesteuert und von einer experten-jury
der nasa bewertet auch maurers trainer
aus köln erwies der wiener schaut
gespannt zu
könnte mich gut verstehen
deutlich geworden anders als in köln
tauchen die astronauten hier in echten
raumanzügen knapp 130 kilo sind die
schwer allein darin die orientierung zu
behalten stellt die astronauten vor
enorme herausforderungen
fünfeinhalb stunden lang läuft es gut
für matthias maurer
[Musik]
sonst kannst du mich hören wie tofu war
okay drückt meine hand wenn du bei
bewusstsein ist keine reaktion wir
standen die personenrettung ich kehre
mit institut zur station zurück maurer
hat das rettungsszenario richtig und
rechtzeitig erkannt er hat jetzt 30
minuten zeit tracy zur luftschleuse zu
schleppen
doch in der hektik macht ihr einen
finger hier hast du hast dich mit den
füßen in den sicherheitsmann verhindert
die rettungsleinen sind maurers
achillesferse
und genau dort haben sie sich verfangen
ich kann mich nicht drehen war kann sich
befragen
doch wie wir die jury das missgeschick
bewirken die touristen sicherheit
ok zeit stoppt gemacht mit ihr wie lange
habe ich gebraucht
was glaubst du wie lange du gebraucht
ist ich schätze so 25 25 ganz gut dass
man 21 minuten
ok ich hätte lieber den leinen fahrrad
vermeiden sollen sechs stunden prüfung
hat mayer hinter sich
nur wenn er hier mit bestnoten
abschneidet wird er bei einer mission
einen der begehrten weltraumspaziergänge
ausführen dürfen
bist du erledigt ja total
das urteil der jury steht noch aus doch
tauchen das team hat ein gutes gefühl
sehr zufrieden hat sich das angeschaut
und er gratuliert von daher weiß mehr
als ich weil er oben dabei war von daher
gehe ich aus dass es hoffentlich gelangt
hatte daher freue ich mich jetzt auf das
meine dusche und dann auf den vier tage
später wird maurer erfahrung dass die
nasa ich mir ihn positiv bewertet hat
und er somit die prüfung bestanden hat
immerhin hatte seine partnerin neun
minuten vor der zeit gerettet
trotz des verbands in den seilen
[Musik]
begleitet die austria aus und von anfang
an und bringt sie nach und nach auf
dieses level
das ist wirklich rührend matthias maurer
wird jetzt zu denen die das zeug für
eine weltraum mission haben das viele
training hat sich gelohnt
und vielleicht ist er nach alexander
gerst der nächste deutsche astronaut im
weltraum
[Musik]